All politics is tribal.
We're not arguing over policies, really.
We're arguing over team colors.
It's one reason why
things are going to become so disastrous.
And so what you need to do is
you need to try to
introduce
a different dynamic of tribalism.
I have a clear vision for what
the forward party can become.
And I'm really excited about it.
It's this unifying
tribe
that's positive and uplifting in politics
that a lot of people
have been waiting for.
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Andrew Yang,
who is arguably one of,
if not the most original thinkers
on the political scene,
best known for his 2020 presidential run
and subsequent New York City mayoral bid,
and also the man who really pioneered
a national conversation
on the merits of universal basic income.
Andrew is the author of a few books
his most recent
being entitled Foreword,
which is a great book.
It's part memoir and also part campaign
trail exposé.
It's an instructive read
on the dysfunctional state
of politics and political media,
the troubling national divide
that is eroding our humanity,
and also a roadmap on
how to best repair the broken spokes
of our democratic system.
It also serves to announce the creation
of a brand new third party
that Andrew has founded the forward party,
which is part of Andrew's plan
to help redress democratic dysfunction
by disrupting America's two party duopoly.
I got to say that I find Andrew's
creative approach
to politics really energizing.
His ideas are fresh. They're bold.
I appreciate his genuineness, his candor,
his humanness, his willingness and ability
to not just think
outside the box,
but actually to take action on new ideas.
And I was very excited to talk to him.
So this is it.
Me and Andrew Yang having a semi wonky
but not too wonky,
relatively Partizan free conversation
about how to best re-imagine
the democratic experiment
for the betterment of all.
Super nice to meet you.
Thank you for coming out here to do
this. It's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, man.
So, so many things to talk about with you.
I followed your journey and your
trajectory has been super fascinating.
And I think, like many, I find myself
despairing about our country's division,
and that's a divide
that seemingly continues to expand
seems to become exacerbated daily.
And that
trajectory feels like
it's in lockstep
with this breakdown in our ability
to effectively communicate
in a healthy way,
which is amplified by this
growing distrust in our institutions
and a decline in the trust
that we've placed in our media landscape
to deliver the news and information
objectively.
And there doesn't seem to be
a shortage of people
who understand this problem
or notice it or recognize it.
Fewer, though, seem to offer solutions,
even fewer creative solutions,
and only a very few who demonstrate
any kind of good faith willingness
to actually tackle the problem
and do something about it.
But I do see all of that in you, which is
one of the reasons why you decided to do
and you do it with, you know,
kind of this beautiful, genuine nature
and with
a sensibility that
you're coming to the table in good faith
with these original and bold ideas
and this and this optimism around the
the untapped potential of our
of our democratic experiments.
I couldn't agree more
that people feel very
pessimistic because polarization
is getting worse and worse.
You see that
more and more Americans
regard their political opponents
as our enemies, and I'm a numbers guy.
So 42% of both Republicans and Democrats
consider the other side either evil
or their mortal enemies,
and we can all feel that
anger rising.
It may well result in political violence
that already has really gone
over the next number of years,
and I want to suggest
that your podcast,
Your Voice, is one of the antidotes.
one of my.
Premises
of the future is that people don't
trust institutions anymore,
they trust other people like people
that have been following your journey
and listen to your advice
and guidance and experiences
have a sense of who you are,
what makes you tick.
And that's what we need right now.
We need to bring people around
to trust each other again.
It starts with trusting individuals
like yourself.
I think that independent media,
like podcasts, is actually
something that we can build on
to try to rebuild trust.
Yeah, I mean, what's so interesting about
your path is that in many ways
you were and are the podcast candidate.
I mean, you were somebody
who was not getting recognized
appropriately in legacy media.
And then you go on Sam Harris,
you go on Joe Rogan
and all the subsequent appearances
that you've made on a variety of podcasts
, not the least of which
being crystal and sogar.
And that really advanced
not only your your profile,
but the policy measures
that you care so deeply about.
And it triggered
this national conversation.
And as somebody you know,
thank you for those kind words.
But as somebody who is a podcaster,
that's really fascinating
just forensically
to observe that in contrast
to the way that legacy legacy media
has has always operated.
And it gives me hope,
and I think you're correct in that
there is a need and an appetite
for long form conversations
when you sit down with somebody
and you talk to them for hours,
and it's a relatively agenda free
scenario
that allows people to get a real feel
and sense of who you are
and where you're coming from.
As opposed to this click baity soundbite,
you know, yell for five
seconds on on cable news ecosystem
that we've grown so accustomed to.
Yeah, it's more like how human beings
interact in real life.
You know you, you sit with someone
and you have a conversation.
I certainly have done more than my fair
share of five minute long cable news hits.
one of the things I say to my
team is that after the cable news hit,
I'd be like any data anyone like.
Go to the website, anyone donate.
And the answer was always No.
Yeah.
So I started to say it's like,
why am I doing these things?
And the answer that I got was legitimacy
was that if you do a cable news hit,
it actually sends a signal to voters
that they're allowed to consider you
because there's a very, very significant
number of voters
who rely upon the media for that framing.
And that's particularly true
among Democrats.
You probably saw
I recently left the Democratic Party,
so now I'm independent, I noticed.
But Democrats
believe in the news media
to a much higher degree than anyone else.
The numbers are 69% of Democrats
have high trust in media.
For independents, it's only 36%.
And for Republicans, it's a whopping 15%.
So this is my way to be
one of the defining elements
of the parties at this point.
But I was running in a Democratic primary,
so having the blessing,
even the tacit blessing of the cable news
networks was important.
Yeah.
Well, one of the more fascinating
aspects of your book,
which I enjoyed very much,
is just your characterization of what
that media complex is like from a boots on
the ground experience from the perspective
of you during the campaign.
And it's very dispiriting to see how
political media, the political media
industrial complex
actually operates in kind of cahoots
with the political parties
to advance certain narratives
and other ones.
And you know, it's it's it's really, yes,
there are podcasts,
but can we see a way forward
to, you know, kind of trends transcend
this quagmire that is keeping us
stuck in a certain status
quo that, you know, by all accounts
and certainly, you know,
by virtue of what you talk about
is not functioning.
And that's one of the main reasons
I wanted to write this book Rich.
I came off the trail
and I will confess to everyone that I did
approximately zero reflection
when I was running for president.
How could you?
There's no.
It's just what's in front of you
to do immediately next.
Yeah, I was like a hammer
where I was like, What's the nail?
What's the nail? And like,
you know, just doo doo doo.
And then when the day ends, you
just kind of,
you know, crawl into bed like I was it
I go to.
And I don't know.
I may take notes for a book,
but I wanted to catalog the journey
for people because I had learned so much
going into the bowels of our media
industrial complex
and our political industrial complex.
And the media incentives are very,
very distorting
as to which candidates they will suppress
and which they will amplify.
I'm not the only candidate who.
Is on the outside looking in.
I mean, I think we all remember in 2016
Bernie versus Hillary,
where they were the kneecapping Bernie
at every turn and the news
media
and the DNC were very much hand in glove.
And you know, there's a different set
of issues on the other side.
But. Being subject to that
did make me very hungry
to try and find alternatives,
and it is one reason
why I'm very confident in my new path
is that the Democrats will be like
the last of the institutional lists,
even as more and more people say, Wait,
this isn't working,
this isn't working
like the Democratic primary.
Voters in particular
are going to be the last people saying,
hang on, it is working
even when the losses.
Well, again, it is because of their trust
in the news media,
and the news media will be hammering
certain messages until the last dog dies.
Essentially,
there there's an institutional mindset
and a trust that many Democrats
naturally have to a higher degree.
If you were to summarize
where the parties are right now,
the Democrats are the people
who are hanging on to the fading
and fumbling institutions,
and then Republicans have been overtaken
with this anti institutional fervor
embodied by Donald Trump.
And what I'm going to suggest is
that a lot of us are not on either
of those sides.
The forward party, which I founded
now, is trying to call attention
to the real defects and issues
our institutions have in the hopes
that we can rejuvenate them,
reform them, build new ones.
That's the kind of positive stance
that a lot of us
wish existed in our politics,
as opposed to the two poles,
which are just going to end up more
and more extreme over time.
Yeah, I want to get into all the forward
party stuff.
But before we do that, I mean,
you mentioned this built in inherent
trust that the Democratic Party has
and institutional
institutions versus
the mindset of Republicans.
And that harkens to the work of Jonathan
Hite, who looms large in your book.
You cite him frequently,
and his studies are quite fascinating
in terms of the psychological differences
between Democrats and Republicans.
So can you elucidate that a little bit?
Yeah.
Jonathan is such an incredible
philosopher, really.
He's a friend as well.
And his work on
the righteous mind, how
Americans can disagree on politics
while still being good people,
I think is one of the most important works
of our time.
So he makes the case that there are six
universal values
in human culture that transcend
national borders.
They are caring, fairness, liberty,
loyalty authority and sanctity.
And it turns out that Democrats and
Republicans respond to different values.
And that list
Democrats tend to respond
more to caring and fairness.
And Republicans tend to respond
and respond
more to loyalty, authority and sanctity.
And then the two sides
define liberty differently.
And so what you see is you have news
media organizations that really hammered
different themes that strike that chord
with their audience.
It's one reason
why the media organizations now
don't seem very objective.
They become increasingly.
Companies that
profit from separating us
into institutional camps,
and they figured out
what Jonathan wrote about,
which is that if you hammer
certain notes or values or symbols,
then you can command much more loyalty
and affection.
one of the main lessons I have here
is that all politics is tribal.
We're not arguing over policies, really,
we're arguing over team colors.
It's one reason why
things are going to become so disastrous.
And so what you need to do is
you need to try to introduce
a different dynamic of tribalism.
one thing I'm going to suggest,
as you would need more than two tribes of
because the last thing you ought to do
is have two great warring tribes.
But Jonathan Height's work did
inform my prescription
because he explains why
it is that we can be so divided
on multiple levels.
Yeah.
On the one hand, it's dispiriting to hear
that media companies
would kind of crack that, that that
psychology
and then weaponize it, on the other hand.
For me,
it allows me to have a deeper appreciation
or level of empathy
for people of different points of view
to understand
that they're just wired differently
and they see the world differently.
And it is a disposition
that is constitutional rather
than kind of the result of influence
or environments.
And the single biggest concern
we should have in this domain
is the dehumanization of different people
of different political beliefs.
And Jonathan posits
that a lot of this is actually genetic
where you're born with a particular
psychological disposition of openness
or sensitivity to threat
or appetite for novelty,
and that ends up
pushing you in one direction or the other.
So if someone voted for Trump
or approves of a certain policy,
it should have nothing to do
with their value
as a human being
or their their worth in that respect.
But unfortunately, in this time, people
regard folks
who have different beliefs
as somehow less worthwhile.
Yeah, I mean, there's
a lack of respect for differentiation
and beliefs and ideology.
I mean, I grew up in Washington, D.C.
I grew up in a kind of
inside the Beltway situation
throughout the late seventies
and early eighties.
And my recollection of that
was that there was a respect
and a level of comedy between party.
You would go to dinner.
My parents would have dinner.
Parties are both sides.
I went to school with people
that were, you know,
the offspring of Politician X, Y and Z.
And these
these people lived in your neighborhood
and in your community,
and there were Republicans and Democrats.
And irrespective of those differences,
there was a respect
that seems to have been completely lost.
And you know, I'm fascinated
by what has catalyzed this.
You know, this divide? I mean, is it all?
Can it be all tracked to media?
Like, is it this, you know, increasing?
Gap in wealth inequality,
like how do you think about how we went
from there to here?
one of the big lessons
I've learned and I'm trying
to convey to people is that if everyone
follows their incentives
in a reasonable way,
we are sunk as a society.
And you ask why it is that?
And I also remember a time when it seemed
like people of different parties
got along as human beings, and now
they see themselves in a different light.
And the reason is incentives,
where I was with a Republican senator
a couple of weeks ago,
and she said that it serves
political interest better if you keep
an issue alive than if you resolve it,
because if you keep an issue alive,
you can just get people mad about it
and blame the other side
and raise a lot of money.
And then if you resolve it, someone on
your side is going to be mad at you.
And one example that I oppose,
she didn't oppose this,
but that came to mind for me
was when Senator Marco Rubio proposed
bipartisan immigration
reform a number of years ago,
and then he pulled it back
about a week later
after getting absolutely hammered
by his own party.
But it was like a sign of
if you do lean forward to compromise,
you're going to get attacked.
So the political incentives
end up driving people to their corners.
And by the numbers, right now,
Congress has a national approval
rating of about 28%.
It's quite low pay doesn't surprise
anyone listening to this.
The reelection rate for individual members
of Congress is 92%, which is sky high.
I mean, that's like a better win
rate than the 2016 Warriors
or something along those lines.
So you dig into that and say,
how can it be
that we can be so dissatisfied
with Congress as a body?
And yet our members always get reelected,
and the mechanics are such
that 83% of the districts in the country
are either very blue or very red.
So the game for me as a representative
is not to serve
51% of the voters in my community.
It's to please and placate
a ten to 20% most extreme Partizan voters
that that are going
to turn out in the primary.
So my political incentives
then are to be more extreme
and ideological than the average person.
And that's why the incentives are
what you just described, which is you have
political incentives that reward people
for being more and more Partizan.
You have media organizations
compounding those incentives
and then now you have social media
pouring gasoline on the whole thing.
Right.
And this is one
reason why the polarization is at a point
where we can literally see ourselves
devolving into Civil War 2.0.
And that sounds hyperbolic and negative.
But a scholar named Peter Turchin
has been measuring political stress,
and he has us presently at civil war
levels.
That's terrifying.
Yeah, and and if if you reflect on it,
we've already seen
heretofore unthinkable scenes
unfolding in the United States
and the question you have to ask yourself
is is that going to get more extreme
or less extreme in the days to come?
I'm going to suggest
it's only going to get more extreme
because that's where
all the incentives are driving us, right?
Meanwhile, just today, I'm sure you saw
the announcement that Trump made around
this new social media media platform
that he's going to be launching,
which to my mind, I mean,
I don't know what your perspective is on.
This is only going to exacerbate
that divide
and further inflame
those perverse incentives.
I'm going to be fascinated
to see how this unfolds.
I am skeptical that he he is
capable of operating a true technological.
His track record is great on this,
but we'll see, right?
But but it is a sign of the times,
for sure.
And it's fascinating
how these tech companies have become
essentially the arbiters of information
and communication for everyone.
Like in a public commons
manner,
I'm friends with some of the folks
at these tech companies.
There are clear excesses on that side.
But I think that the issues are not
what Trump and the gang are proposing.
Those aren't the real problems.
Mean, a lot of the problems are around
our deteriorating mental health
as a result of social media use,
particularly among young people,
particularly among teenage girls.
And there are probably people
that listen to this podcast or parents
who are concerned about it.
The data shows that what the Facebook
whistleblower
Francis Hogan proposed,
like a lot of people I know
in Silicon Valley, already knew this,
I'm sure the same is true for you.
Yeah, yeah.
And as a parent of teenagers,
I'm hyper aware of this
and this is a subject
that's come up frequently on the podcast.
And it's it's it's heartbreaking.
And I think the, you know,
the solution remains to be seen.
I mean, it's a very
difficult problem to tackle.
I propose
a couple of solutions in the book,
but one thing that I thought was common
sense is just turn off Instagram
between the hours of midnight
and 8:00 a.m.
You know, for your kid,
if there's a minor.
Yeah.
I mean, do they really need
to be on Instagram those hours?
You know, we should be able
to take measures like that.
Yeah, it's it's tricky, though,
as somebody who has teenagers right
now, it's it's a very difficult thing
to actually put in place.
Well, you could go to the company level.
I don't know if I were president,
I would seriously be talking to folks
and be like, Look, what are common
sense measures we could take?
And of course,
some people would hate them,
and some people would say, like,
you know, you're being heavy handed.
But we have to look at the data.
I mean, the data shows that this stuff's
not great in over abundance.
Mm-Hmm.
On the subject of of perverse incentives,
the kind of traditional approach
to that has been,
you know, kind of policy piecemeal like,
let's look at campaign finance reform.
Let's tackle the filibuster.
Let's, you know, try to, you know,
figure out how to overcome gerrymandering.
You're so you have a variety of solutions
that are all outlined in the book.
And you know,
you've got this mission statement
that's based on a number of categories.
But at the very top level, it's
about upending this duopoly
and this is where the forward
party comes in.
Why is this in your mind the best way
to deal with all of these problems?
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want to snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits,
vegetables, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however,
without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve
this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say, is the plant power
meal planner are affordable,
all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic
grocery delivery, and you get access
to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many other features
to learn more and to sign
up, visit meals that rich WorldCom.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual
membership when you use the promo code
RR Health at checkout.
This is life changing stuff.
People for just a dollar, 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals that rich WorldCom
promo code our health
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right.
Let's get back to the show.
So when I went on this journey,
you writing this book,
talking about my own experiences
and also trying to unpack
this sense of frustration
and despair that I felt genuinely
where my campaign achieved
very unlikely levels of success.
Are we our competed half a dozen senators,
governors, political brand names?
And yet I still felt like we were very far
from delivering on some of the changes
that we were fighting for.
I thought the problem was that people
had not heard of universal basic income.
And it turns out that,
you know, now that people have heard of it
and 65% of people are for it
now, I realize the problem
is that our government
actually isn't working
and isn't set up to respond to us.
And so if a system's designed not to work,
then you should expect it not to work.
That was like one of my big takeaways.
And then when you get back
to first principles,
it turns out that our founding fathers
were anti Partizan.
There's nothing in the Constitution
about political parties.
John Adams said that
if you had two great parties,
it would be an evil upon the land.
You know, they're this
duopoly
design is a design catastrophe, really.
You can see it now with the rising
polarization, and a lot of people sense
this.
62% of Americans right now want
an alternative to the two major parties.
The two major parties command
very low, genuine loyalty.
Independents outnumber Democrats
and Republicans by almost two to one.
The numbers are something like 44%
independent 2825 are
Republican approximately.
So if you were an entrepreneur,
as I would consider you
to be and other people listening to
this might resemble this.
If you're an entrepreneur
and you showed up to a market,
there were two companies
and 62% of people wanted an alternative.
You would immediately
want to start a third company.
You would say, Hey, let's do this now.
In politics, the mechanics make it very,
very difficult
to actually start a third party.
But if you look around the world,
the UK has five parties
Germany seven, Sweden eight,
the Netherlands 18.
These are mature democracies
that also are much more resistant
to authoritarianism
because if you have only two major parties
and then one of them succumbs
to bad leadership, all of a sudden
the political incentives for everyone in
that party are to fall in line.
You know, our guy might not be perfect,
but he's better than the other team.
And then you can actually find yourself in
an authoritarian environment
very, very quickly.
It's very, very vulnerable.
It's a very poor design.
So the question is,
how could we actually improve
on the design in a short timeframe?
We might have, for example, 13 months
to try to improve the design.
It sounds impossible,
but one of the revelations that I found
is that there's actually a path for us
to do it, for us to make a more multiparty
democracy genuinely possible
to give rise to different points of view,
to give independents a voice.
And because the Constitution
does not talk at all
about political parties, all of this is
determined at the state level.
So it turns out that 25 states have ballot
initiative provisions where if enough
people get together, we can change the way
the party primaries work.
And one state Alaska has already made this
change, which I'm happy to talk about.
But they shifted from closed party
primaries
to open primaries and ranked choice
voting in 2020.
And we've already seen direct results
of that change.
Yeah.
Well, historically, you know,
I don't have to tell you that that that,
you know,
throughout the history of America,
you know, there's been issues with trying
to get a third party off the ground,
the most famous being Ross Perot,
which was rather anemic.
And what seems qualitatively different
about what you're doing
is that the focus of of this third party
isn't necessarily completely
honed in on presidential politics.
It almost functions as a support group
for other parties
who are behind some of these policy policy
initiatives that that you support.
So it's it's kind of a broader blanket
in terms of it is impacting politics
from the local level
all the way up to
perhaps the presidential level.
We are very practical.
It's true rich, but you are the
you are the practical guy.
Yeah, I am.
I am the math guy and the operator.
But I do want to rewind for a moment
and say that Ross
Perot
got a 19.3% of the popular vote in 92,
and a friend of mine who were, well,
just let him
remain anonymous, pulled himself in
2020 and had himself at 25%.
And he was an
alternative to the two major candidates.
So you are seeing significant levels
of support for an alternative mean.
I think if there was a Ross
Perot type figure now,
you would do much better than 19.2%.
So just to let you know, like,
you know, the
the president isn't quite
as you know, like negative as as
some might think,
but we are very practical in that
the forward party is focused on
actually changing the mechanics.
We're going to support ballot initiatives
to try and shift
to open primaries and ranked choice
voting in states around the country.
And you can participate in help
as a registered Democrat,
as a registered Republican,
as an independent.
We say you don't need to change your party
registration because the fact is doing
so might reduce your ability
to participate in elections
in 83% of the country.
You know who would do that.
So job one is to actually open up
the mechanics of the system.
And I want to talk a little bit about
just how dramatic this impact could be.
So a senator, Lisa
Murkowski of Alaska, has been in the news
a lot over the last number of weeks
because she is the only Republican senator
who voted to impeach Donald Trump,
who is also up for reelection next year.
All right.
Her approval rating right now
among Alaskan Republicans is 6%
as a result.
It's political suicide to do what she did.
But because Alaska just shifted
to open primaries and ranked choice
voting, she doesn't have to go through
just the ten to 20%
the most Partizan Republicans in Alaska.
She can take her case
to the general public,
where she now has a fighting chance to win
because a lot of people like and respect
and admire Senator Murkowski.
So I want people to imagine
listening to this if we were to unlock,
let's call it ten U.S.
senators from
there are hyper Partizan Cage
and let them be able to represent
51% of their constituents,
as opposed to just the ten
to 20% on one side.
How many would then have different
stances?
Be able to vote on principle around things
like protecting
our democratic institutions or local
secretaries of state from getting fired
for political reasons or whatever
the measures are?
I think that is a real concrete
goal that we can be shooting for in 2022
that might help our country
get through the next number of months.
Yeah, I really like this idea of open
primaries and ranked choice voting.
I suspect that
some people watching or listening
may have heard those terms,
but don't quite understand what they mean.
We have seen ranked choice
voting in a number of states.
Has there been that combination, though,
other than the example
that you just illustrated
of those two working together,
the open primaries with the ranked choice
voting because we've typically seen
ranked choice
voting within primary races solely?
That is correct.
Alaska is the only state that's installed,
both of them in conjunction.
Maine has had ranked choice
voting in their elections
for the last number of years,
and it's had very positive results.
I was in a ranked choice voting election
that I didn't your California
right
and then ranked choice voting itself.
But that was with it.
That was in the primary race.
It was which which,
you know, solved some of the problem.
And not all of it.
But ranked choice voting
generally has a moderating influence
because you have to get 50.1% of voters
to at least
have you somewhere on their ballot.
And so if you're the kind of candidate
that's
going to really excite 25% of people,
but then turn off 60%, like that's
not a winning strategy,
then a ranked choice voting contest,
whereas it could be a winning strategy
and a plurality voting contest.
So it's going to reward coalition
builders.
It's going to discourage
negative campaigning
because if I trash you,
then we both look kind of bad
and the third candidate
does a relatively better.
So it's a kind of process upgrade
that can have profound impacts
on both the types of leaders
you elect, but also their incentives
after they're in
and the incentives of the voters
themselves get realigned. Yes.
And you know, another thing too,
is that when you talk about a third party,
what's the first thing someone says
you're going to mess it up for Party
X or Party Y?
And ranked choice
voting gets rid of that spoiler effect
because you can express your
true preferences, you can.
Rank the minor party candidate number one
and then your favorite major party
candidate, number two,
and then it doesn't mess anything up
for anyone. Right.
So when when people talk about the spoiler
effect,
it's baked into this doo-wop,
there's a kind of a circularity to it.
It's like, Well,
why can't you have new parties?
Because you're going screwed up for party
exits.
It's like, Well,
if you change the process,
then people can express their preferences
in a more honest and representative way.
So that's where we should be racing to
as quickly as possible.
This is one of the things
I'm trying to convey to folks is like this
system is setting us up to fail.
And even if you love one side
more than the other,
you should still be investing
very, very quickly in these reforms
because it's going to make it
so that the system might survive
the next number of months.
Mm hmm.
On that point of,
you know, being devil's advocate
and you're going to mess it up
and all of that, what is your sense of?
The people who are gravitating
towards the forward party,
I mean, obviously this is early days,
you know, and my sense would be
that it's going to be kind of conservative
Democrats and progressive Republicans
or centrist
Republicans, sensible Republicans
who are not far right.
Is there
a notion around
what that balance looks like?
Is it going to be
more of those Republicans versus Democrats
or how does that pass out?
I've got an early outreach
from a lot of Republicans
and independents, including military,
like including
many military veterans and law enforcement
folks who just are drawn to it.
They've said to me, like,
I've been waiting for something like this
for a long time,
but all politics are tribal again.
And the question
is, who's going to be drawn to this
set of solutions, this approach,
this political language?
And I've been joking that
it's like the most reasonable,
optimistic, entrepreneurial solutions
oriented
10% of Americans.
It's not 51%.
That's one of the fun things about it.
But in a country this polarized,
if you get 10% of Americans
excited about a particular movement,
you actually control the agenda.
If you look at the US Senate,
how many senators would
you need to control the agenda right now?
11? Yeah, exactly.
Like, there's a chance that we get our one
senator in 22.
You know, so
when people look at this, this
movement, it really is like this
solutions oriented,
reasonable 10% and that maps to different
parts of the political spectrum.
Yeah,
without getting too Partizan
on any of this.
I mean, I'm no fan of Donald Trump,
but when I look at when I cast my gaze
at 2024, I'm trying to imagine forward
party or no forward party
the scenario under which
Donald Trump does not win the election.
Like, how are you thinking about that
and how that's going to play out?
So I've looked at the political landscape
ahead.
The betting markets right now
have Republicans retaking the House
of Representatives at 72% next fall,
which seems about right right now.
Democrats have a five seat advantage.
Traditionally, the Empower Party loses
ten to 15 seats in the off cycle election.
So most people in DC are looking at it,
saying, well, the Democrats have
until November 22 to get anything done
because they're going to lose the House.
Mm hmm. So at that point,
you're not going to see many
legislative victories for Democrats
that they can champion heading into 24.
Right now, Joe's approval
rating is in the low to mid forties.
It could obviously change dramatically
over the next number of months.
So if you're the Democrats,
who do you run against Trump first?
I'll go to the Republican field
very quickly.
It's going to be Trump
in all likelihood, 65%
approval rating his strongest opponents
have said they won't run against him.
So he probably rolls through Chris
Christie, Mike Pence,
maybe Larry Hogan
like that, that kind of field.
So then if you're the Democrats
and you see Trump come in, you say, OK,
who are we going to run?
Joe Biden, incumbent
president, defeated and once.
The major drawback for Joe is that
he'll be 81 years old
and his health is going to be an issue.
He might visibly be showing some signs of
wear.
So then you look around and say, OK,
maybe Kamala.
The problem is that Kamala polls
four to five points worse than Joe
pretty consistently have a chance.
So and then if you were to try
and find a third person,
you can't just appoint that person.
They have to go through
a competitive primary,
which is something the Democrats would not
want to to to put themselves through.
So it's probably Joe. Mm-Hmm.
So to your point, then if you see the
the Biden Trump rematch, who wins
and a lot of people don't realize that
this past race was razor
thin in terms of the margin
where 42,000 voters in three states
had voted differently.
Trump wins legitimately via
the Electoral College vote.
So who would you favor
in terms of Biden, Trump too?
You know,
it's a difficult frankly, it's
a difficult scenario
to feel confident
about Biden winning again.
And so if you were the Democrats,
this is your landscape,
you know, and it's a tough landscape.
So that that's something that's
another reason why I think that we need
to be trying to think more systemically
about what solutions look like.
And since charting the forward party,
I've had a lot of Democrats be like,
Hey, hey, you know, like, you know,
pretty much like vote Democrat all
or all the way, like Trump's coming like ,
you know?
There's there's no room for a distraction,
and I look at this and be like, well,
you know,
you can obviously do what you want to do
in terms of supporting Democrats,
but you have to look at this map
and I'm the numbers guy like,
this is going to be really tough.
And so if that's your
plan, it would be very wise to have a Plan
B, right?
Well, on that subject of of policy
initiatives, things that we can be doing
now, in addition
to open primaries and ranked choice
voting, which we should point out, I can't
remember whether you said it or not.
These are ballot initiatives
that don't require legislative action.
So these are things that can actually
happen on the state level
and make a real difference
in the immediate future.
But in addition to that, a huge piece
of your platform with the forward
party is this idea of human centered
capitalism, right?
Like the idea that we need
to reconfigure our economy
so that it is not so hyper focused on GDP
and start taking care of the people,
as opposed to just making sure
that the economy is churning
and using that to overindex
on how we're actually doing as a country.
You know, if you look at the measurements
around such basic things
as infant mortality, quality, drinking
water access, public education,
life expectancy,
the United States is 28th in the world
on those
measurements, worse for some of them,
and that's been declining over
the last number of years.
one of the cases I was making
when I ran for president is like,
look like our quality of life
is sinking into the mud.
People are getting increasingly angry
and distraught and resentful.
So that's what we should be investing in.
In my prescription at the time was
we should give everyone
1000 bucks a month,
and I think that that would help them
a great deal.
But equally important is for us to focus
on the right measurements
because if you're an operator, as I am,
if you have the wrong measurements, you're
going to head in the wrong direction .
And right now we're pretending
things are good
while people's quality of life
just gets worse and worse.
So we should be centering our sense
of progress around how our kids are doing
our health, our mental health,
our environmental quality.
And then if those things decline,
then you can look up and say,
Wow, we're really doing poorly
as opposed to right now saying, Well,
we must be doing OK because GDP is up,
stock market prices are at record highs.
And you know,
there's a certain subset of us
that are doing well
in terms of the financial returns
other than UBI,
which you've spoken about at length
many, many times, obviously.
What are some other ways that we can
address the growing wealth disparity
and this gap,
which feels like the real engine
behind the division that gets played out
in the media and in politics?
Yeah.
The simplest explanation for what's
going on in our country
is that if you destroy a middle class,
then you become subject to all sorts
of terrible impulses and ideas.
And our middle class
has been getting decimated for decades,
starting in the mid-seventies around
when I was born.
Actually, I was born in 75.
I spent six years
running an entrepreneurship organization
because I thought the way
that we could remedy this is to have
people starting businesses and growing
businesses all over the country.
And I realized that the scope of my work
was going to be far too small
to try to remedy the problem in question.
So if you're going to try and rebuild
the middle class, it's a massive project.
But there are three
main things that make Americans sad
in terms of their costs
education, health care and housing.
Each of those has gone up in price
much, much more so than incomes for one,
but also then the the consumer goods
or media or other things that we consume.
So if you were to want to try
and make things better in America,
you would find ways to deliver
health care more cost effectively.
You would find ways to make education
less costly and you try and keep
the housing price,
housing prices and costs under control.
So from the inception
of this conversation around UBI
that that you helped pioneer
and now is by dint of the pandemic
actually has been tested.
Has your
how has your perspective on UBI evolved
or changed since those early days
during the presidential campaign?
We're living through now real time
experiments
with UBI at scale,
which in some ways very exciting.
The biggest component is the child
tax credit
that has lifted millions of kids
and families out of poverty.
It's made people better able to learn it's
put food on the table.
442 economists,
including Nobel Prize winners, recently
signed a letter saying
Keep the child tax credit.
Because it's the best thing
we have done in a long time.
So that's a component that I think people
are very excited about and confident in.
The other component around unemployment
relief
has had very, very mixed effects,
in large part because we've tied the money
to not working.
And I'm around
26 year olds who say to me, Look,
I'm getting 80% of what I was making,
not working,
so I'm not going to do anything
until this train runs out.
Now a bunch of those people
and then only then will
I turn around and start looking for a job,
and I look at them
and I say that's entirely reasonable
and rational.
Like, you know, like who?
Who would make a different decision?
So if we're going to put money
into people's hands,
we should not be
attaching it to not working.
That's one of
the big lessons that I think
people should take from this time.
Mm-Hmm.
How do you think about campaign
finance reform and the pernicious nature
of the lobbying industrial complex
and the impact that that has on
on elected official incentives
like how can we get passed K Street?
How can we figure out
how to responsibly channel money
into politics without creating those types
of incentives?
Because short of serious campaign
finance reform, like how?
How do we like to use your phrase
like move forward?
This is one of the great issues,
and I talk in the book about
how now we have a Eatocracy
where for big companies,
you'll spend millions of dollars
not just trying to get something done,
but making sure something
you don't like doesn't happen.
And that's like this negative power
now in the system.
Like, you can't get anything done, but
you can keep anything from getting done
right. You know, like you.
And that's fueled by this revolving door
between K Street
and the Fortune 500 C-suites
unelected office.
Yes, there was an onion headline
from a long time ago an article,
but you can look it up.
It's like the American people hire
a lobbyist to fight for their interests
in Washington,
and I just thought it was really funny.
There's like a guy to see the picture
being like,
I represent the American people,
and then I thought about it like that.
I actually would make a lot of sense.
And what's funny is, years later,
after that headline, I started
a lobbying organization, humanity forward
that right now is doing that very thing.
It's just like in Washington DC, it's
lobbying for cash relief and data rights.
We want you to actually do your job.
So I want you to do your job
for the American people
and not like an interest group that has
oodles and oodles of money, right?
So that sounds good to people.
You know, you can check out
humanity forward, and it's literally
like the people's lobbyists, right?
Inspired by the onion.
So it's a it's a major problem.
We spend
billions of
dollars like a vortex of $6 billion plus
influencing policy,
just trying to keep things fixed in place.
So how do you cut through that?
And the customary political
answer that you'll hear is
we should overturn Citizens United,
try and get dark money out of politics.
I agree it was a bad ruling,
but it would take a constitutional
amendment to overturn that ruling.
And the fact is, money has had its way
in politics since even before
that ruling and would find its way back in
in various ways.
So the best actual solution,
which I think could be achievable
and passable, is to put 100
democracy dollars into the hands
of every American that you can just give
to any political candidate you want.
This has been done at a local level,
and it has empowered people
to all of a sudden think of themselves
as investors in candidates.
The number of Americans,
the percentage of Americans who actually
donate to political candidates
right now is very low.
It's something like 10%.
So if you do
that, you're in like the most 10%
and the
most engaged and activated
10% of American voters.
But if you had 100 free dollars,
like what would that percentage look like?
You know, all of a sudden
you'd I think you'd see it.
You wouldn't get to 100% ever
because people would.
Some people would be like,
Oh, it's another scam, somehow.
But if you even got to 20 or 25%,
that would be enough to counterbalance
all of the corporate money in politics.
And if you're an individual candidate?
And you got 10,000 people to support you.
That's $1,000,000. That's enough
to run a credible congressional campaign
in a lot of the country.
I like that idea.
And short of Citizens United getting,
you know, overturned.
Isn't there a
way to create a moratorium on
an elected officials
ability to then transition
into some kind of lobbying job?
Or, you know, being on the board
of directors of a company that donated
a tremendous amount of money to them?
Like, can't we at least create space
between the the
the tenure that they hold in office
and whatever they choose
to do when that when they retire
from that office?
The revolving door is so deep
where a majority of legislators
will go work for a lobbyist
after their term in office.
And the dynamic is very pervasive
and pernicious, and it goes like this.
I'm working on Capitol Hill
and I have friends who resemble this.
I make a certain amount of money.
There are lobbyists come around
and they make more money than me.
Their firms,
like pay people six times more.
And so you're very natural.
Impulses go easy on them
and then get a job with them afterwards.
So if you were to genuinely
want to put a stop to this,
you need to do something dramatic,
which I'd be all for.
And in some ways, people would resist this
because it seems like your,
you know, like somehow
rewarding legislators at a higher level.
But we should pay them a lot more
and then we should throw money
at them as soon as they leave office,
as long as they aren't a lobbyist.
Essentially to say, Hey, if you go work
for a nonprofit or an academic institution
that's not engaged in lobbying,
we'll give you an extra hundred
thousand dollars a year for the rest of
your life, whatever it takes.
But that is the
only realistic countermeasure
that might work.
Members of Congress get paid $174,000
a year.
It's a lot of money by national standards,
but a lot of people listening to
this are like, Oh, right, you know,
like, I can see, why did they turn around
and make 800,000 as a lobbyist
as soon as they can?
Yeah.
Part of your whole thing here,
being an entrepreneur
and a technologist is
all of these ideas that you have around
modernizing government and leveraging
technology and blockchain to kind of
bring bureaucracy into the modern era.
I mean, right now, it's just it's insane
how backward it is in terms of,
you know, how it you know how it manages
its day to day operations.
And I really like some of these ideas
that you have.
And in the book,
I thought the story around citizen citizen
use that thing that you tried to start
was very instructive around
what the solution could be versus
kind of where we're at right now
and the barriers towards getting something
like that up on its feet.
Yeah, I was trying to figure out
how to get people money
during the pandemic,
and I told the stories in the book
about how Togo, the poor African country,
actually set up a way for millions
of their citizens to get money digitally.
The way that the U.S.
government distributed
the money was via the IRS.
And that had some virtues,
but it had some real defects as well.
And the biggest effect in that case
was that the poorest Americans
don't actually file taxes.
And so you'd be missing tons of people
that are the most.
Yeah, that needed the most.
And so what some technologists
associated with me
came up with is like, we should have
a citizens portal where you just go.
And then if you wanted to,
we could send your money.
We could send you information,
you could update your passport.
You might be able to get information
about your local elections like that.
There are things that are very,
very feasible and achievable for us.
And one of the jokes I tell
is that if our government were a vendor,
we would have switched years ago.
It would have been like with vendors
not working for me.
The problem is that
there's no other vendor to turn to.
And so one of the
things we should be trying to
emphasize politically
is just better systems that deliver.
And right now, one of the struggles
that Joe Biden is having, in my opinion,
is that he gets in there.
And then there's a problem
born of the bureaucracy inherent
in that everyone blames him for it.
It's because we have this myth
that it's like,
Oh, if I put a competent moral person
in charge, then all of a sudden
the bureaucracy will perform,
and it probably won't, you know,
so that that's one reason why the parties
will just continue to play.
You lose.
I lose over and over again
because whoever's in charge,
things don't work
very well
and we get more and more ticked off.
Well,
there's also just a lack of expertize
in government with respect to technology.
I mean, we all saw, you know, the hearings
with Zuckerberg and all of that,
and it becomes very clear that there just
isn't the depth of understanding
that is needed or required
to solve some of these problems,
which could be solved very easily
through technological solutions.
Oh yeah, it's a travesty.
They got rid of the Office of Technology
Assessment, which was the agency that.
Advised Congress on technology
matters in the 1990s
and haven't had anyone in that capacity
since.
We also do have a jarring autocracy
in this country where the leadership
is quite old and a lot of them
don't understand technology natively
because many of them haven't used it.
Mm hmm. I like this idea.
one of my favorite ideas that you propose
in the book is the tax Mandalorian,
if you would.
Yeah.
Well, I was I was talking to friends
about how
we have
like a very, very sophisticated
finance and legal industry.
But then you have the IRS that's
kind of behind the times on the resource
and everything else.
And so one of my friends said,
You know what,
if you just put out a bounty and said,
if I can wrangle someone who owes
lots of taxes like I get to keep 25%,
you'd have private equity firms
investing in that at a high level.
It was like kind of
jujitsu is like turning the
the sophistication
of the finance industry against itself.
And so we had a good laugh about that.
But it was just a sign, too,
of how we expect our government
to just be limping along.
And how has the
Democratic Party or your friends
within the Democratic Party
responded to you in the wake of the book
coming out and this announcement?
I've been an independent for approximately
two and a half weeks,
and I have enjoyed it immensely.
So if you're an independent, you know,
now like, I see how much fun it is.
I mean, I genuinely felt
as if my point of view changed after
I just changed that voter
registration information.
It's kind of wild that the Democrats
who reached out to me are friends
and good people like, you know,
some of them sent me generous notes.
You know, others,
you know, like,
I've just ignored it, honestly.
But um,
but the people that know me know that I'm
just a solutions oriented builder,
and I'll do whatever
I think is going to work best
in a particular situation and in context.
And right now,
if we're going to free ourselves
out of the duopoly, it's
going to take a popular movement
of independents
and Democrats and Republicans alike.
I have a clear vision for what
the forward party can become.
And I'm really excited about it.
It's this unifying tribe
that's positive and uplifting in politics
that a lot of people
have been waiting for.
Then we talk about actual solutions
and try and bring
the force of popular will to bear.
Mm-Hmm.
There is this narrative out there
that this book and the forward
party is sort of, you know, there's a,
you know, very cynical perspective
that it's a publicity grab,
but it doesn't appear to really be
in your self-interest to put a book out
and announce a third party out there.
I mean, nobody in the Democratic Party
can publicly endorse
what you're doing right now.
And it becomes a political liability to
kind of side stand side by side with you.
Anyone who thinks starting a third
party is like a savvy career move.
Yeah, I really agree.
I really needed to look back to
the podcast studio, Andrew.
Now, you know,
so and I can actually explain the process
because,
you know, I think it might be instructive
for people rich.
So I'm unpacking my experiences
and my learnings.
Reading books by Jonathan Hyatt and Ezra
Klein and Lawrence
Lessig and Catherine Gale
and Michael Porter,
and coming to the conclusions
that I came to in this book forward.
And when you come to these conclusions,
then you have to come to grips with, OK,
what is an actual way out?
What is a real path forward?
What's the solution?
And it would need to be from outside
of the duopoly that actually reforms
our mechanisms so that different
points of view can emerge.
I'm not after three parties, I'm after
five parties having parties, you know,
a democracy that will actually stand up
to the test of time and listen to people.
And so when you draw that conclusion,
there are two ways to end this book.
one is someone should do this or two.
I will do this.
And it turns out that I am
maybe one of the best situated
people in American life to do it.
So I just did not have it in me
to be like,
Here's this devastating crisis
that's unfolding before our eyes.
Here's a solution someone else.
Take care of this, please.
You know, like, I'm
just not wired that way.
I mean, my last book was about a vision
for the country,
and I ran for president on it.
So for this,
if you'd come to this conclusion,
then you think, OK, I have to take action.
And so I always knew
that when this book came out,
I was going to start the forward party
and try and bring this vision to people.
And that's the way that it unfolded
in terms of the process.
But it took me a year of writing
and research to figure out
that this is where we should go. Yeah.
You mentioned on a recent podcast,
on your own podcast
this idea that, you know,
we're all very good at talking.
About the problems, but the minute
somebody says I'm actually going to invest
in the solution and do something about it,
everybody's like, Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You know, we can't do that.
That's what we have to talk about.
We have to talk about the problem.
Yeah, that's a disease
in American life right now is that
if I talk about the problem,
I'm smart, I'm sophisticated.
But if I say, Hey, I'm
going to do something about it,
then people are like,
Oh, no, like, too controversial.
Too political, too inflammatory.
No. So that's a problem.
You know, one of the things
that I think I bring to the
table is like, I will advance a solution
that a lot of people are thinking about.
Like again, 62% of Americans
want an alternative to the duopoly.
And so if you propose the forward party,
open primaries,
ranked choice voting, unlock us
from this death spiral of polarization.
Some Americans look up and say,
Thank God, someone's doing it like I'm in.
But the kind of peanut gallery
approach is like, Oh, can't work.
Here's why.
Because that's one of the ways
we're conditioned nowadays.
Mm-Hmm.
When you look at countries across Europe,
you obviously see democratic nations
with a proliferation of of parties.
Why is it in America
that we've never been able to do that?
So this duopoly again did not
happen with the founding of the country
or the Constitution.
It arose a number of years
and decades later.
The Republican Party was founded
as an anti slave
northern party
in the wake of the Civil War.
So at this point,
you had these two parties, the Democratic
and Republican Party,
that govern the mechanics and made it
so that it's very, very difficult
for a third party to emerge.
Interestingly, though,
the Democratic and Republican Party
were not as ideological as they are
now until quite recently.
And as our Klein's book,
Why We're Polarized,
he goes through the fifties, the sixties,
where the Democrats and Republicans
are essentially interchangeable.
They have like the same outlook,
the same policy prescriptions.
And Americans did not regard
someone of the other party
as anything, but it's like, Oh,
you know that this as the other team, but
we're not super different.
And then the differences started
started emerging
in the sixties, seventies, eighties,
and then they just gone up and up
since then.
But the mechanics have remained
fixed over this time
where over the last 150 years or so,
the two parties said, You know what,
let's just make it so that it's one of us.
And and as a result,
we have now again one of the greatest
design flaws in history
that everyone's trying to convince us
is carved into a stone tablet somewhere.
And when really it's just,
you know, two parties
decided they'd they'd rather it
be one of them and not anyone else?
Yeah.
When you look at countries across
Western Europe, though, I mean, it's
not like a third a third party
or multiple parties is the panacea.
I mean, we're seeing this rise
of nationalism,
you know, across Western Europe,
and there are other problems
that multiple parties don't necessarily
inherently by and of themselves solve.
But my sense is that yes,
it's these policies that are the platform
of this party that you're behind,
that are the crucial driver.
It's the part
it's having a third party itself,
but it's also
what is the mission of this third party?
Yeah.
And if you had a more genuinely dynamic
political system, then new ideas
and policies would get advanced much,
much more quickly than is the case now.
You're right, it's not a panacea.
I mean, obviously,
we'd still have problems.
But I will say
that it'd be much more resilient to,
for example, authoritarian impulses.
It would give people a sense
that they could have
a different point of view and run on it
and not be completely marginalized
and locked out of the system.
Because in the majority of the country
right now and people listening to this
know exactly what I'm talking about,
you cannot meaningfully vote
in your local elections
unless you sign up for one party
or another.
It's a closed party primary.
That was the case in New York City,
where 900,000 people voted
in the Democratic primary
that I participated in,
which was a significant increase, maybe
like an 11% increase from the prior cycle.
But there are 9 million people
in New York City.
I mean, it's actually 10% of people.
Yeah, but the site of the next right?
Right, right.
And it's because you needed to be
a registered Democrat
for months
prior to the election in order to vote.
I encountered
dozens, maybe hundreds of independents
and Republicans who would say, Hey Yang,
we want to vote for you. Like,
you know, like, how do I do it?
And then I'd look at the count
and be like, Hey, it's March, April, May.
Like, you actually are already too late.
Mm hmm. Yeah, that doesn't make sense.
And that's why, you know, ranked choice
voting without open primaries is only,
you know, half a solution.
Agree open primaries
would allow more people to participate.
And if your.
Lowercase D Democratic.
You know, we should all be for this.
I mean, what is the counterargument
that the parties know best
and you should only be allowed to vote?
There are so many people
who've signed up for a party,
not because of their love for that party,
but just because of practicality
or convenience,
or that they just wanted to be able
to participate
like they have this artificial
lock on everything.
It's a problem.
It's also on the local level, exacerbated
by the fact that there's
this dearth of local media
because of the incentives built
in the media,
like there's no local coverage
of any meaning anymore, seemingly,
which then creates that gap
between the voter and truly being educated
about what's going on in their district
. You know,
over 2000
local papers have gone out of business
over the last number of months,
and it's very,
very negative for our ability
to come together
because local papers tended
to be much less polarized and polarizing.
I mean, you know, how many different ways
can you talk about the new store opening
or the yeah, like the bridge, the.
Yeah, yeah.
So, you know,
it's like fairly objective stuff.
So it makes me very sad that local
journalism is dying to the extent it is.
There is an act in Congress
called the Local Journalism
Sustainability Act
that would help someone.
Mm hmm.
But this is to me one of the reasons
why we're spiraling in the way that we are
because they counterweight of local
journalism is disappearing
when you are running for president.
How is it different
than what you expected or anticipated
it would be because, you know,
a big part of the book is pulling covers
on the truth behind, you know,
how kind of this whole situation operates.
And it's pretty revealing for the reader
to understand that
what you see on television
isn't exactly what's what's going on.
There's there's so much more at play
and you know, you like when you were,
you know, at the debate and you said,
you know, what are we all doing here?
Make up.
It's like, I think people were really like
that was so refreshing to hear, like,
let's just call this what it is like,
what are we actually doing here?
What is really going on? Yeah, that was
that was
a line that broke through happily.
Those debates were a very odd experience,
for sure.
So I was a serial entrepreneur prior
to running for president,
and I have made the same mistake
and everything I've ever done, which maybe
some people can relate to.
This is, I thought that
the new thing I was going to do
is going to be somewhat similar
to the last thing I did.
And so how could running
for president bear
any resemblance
to being a tech entrepreneur?
OK, so I was a CEO of a private company,
and then I started
a nonprofit venture for America.
And if you started a nonprofit,
you have to walk around,
make your case, raise money, get support.
And so I thought, OK,
running for president, I'll be like that.
And it was not because it turns out
when you are a candidate,
you become the product yourself.
It's much more direct and personal.
And and I write about this in the book.
You become more of an instrument
where there are people around you
who are just directing you saying,
Do this, do that because
your base is like , you know, like the
main value driver of the campaign.
Like, if I just put my, you know, like
if I just record a quick video for someone
and that's like the most high impact thing
that can be done.
And it was not like that when I was
running a company ever or a nonprofit.
You know, it's like
when I was running those organizations, it
was more about the organization than me.
And so it was a massive adjustment
having to put myself forward in that way.
I'm also Asian, and it might not be,
you know, the way I was brought up.
And so as a result, imagine an introvert
running for president.
That was really my experience.
And so when I was up on that debate stage,
it really did seem farcical
and ridiculous,
and I wanted to try and share that.
And I think that one reason why people
got excited about my campaign is a sense
that I was like an outsider to the system
trying to make sense of it.
For the vast
majority of Americans who had suspected
things maybe weren't as on the up and up.
And so I hope the book conveys
that set of experiences.
Yeah, I mean, being the math guy,
the practical guy,
the policy wonk who wants to talk about
these new creative initiatives.
It's, you know.
Interesting to come and do an awareness
that, you know, people
don't want to talk about policy,
they don't necessarily vote on policy.
And what's really impactful is a video
on somebody's phone of you dancing.
Yeah, and that's what gets coverage.
I mean, just today, like this morning,
I'm like, OK, what's Andrew up to lately?
Like what's happened in the last week
or a couple of days?
I googled your name,
and most of the top hits were all
about your logo for the forward party
looking like Top Gun or GI Joe.
Right?
It's like most of the media
coverage is about that.
So like when you see that, like,
are you like, what do I have to do?
Well, it's
funny, because that was literally
just a designer like actually cool down.
Like, I know if it's intentional,
obviously it's not a mistake.
Yeah, it's just like, Oh, yeah, that's
I grew up in that area.
Yeah, I do talk about this in the book
where, you know,
I spend three days in South Carolina
and then one minute video of my dancing
the cupid shuffle becomes
the only thing anyone cares about
from that trip,
even though I did dozens of other things.
So there's like a media environment,
a social media environment,
and you do want to compete, so
you kind of play into it if you're smart.
You know what?
What's one of the things that I found
will hold back other candidates
is that everyone is surrounded
by staff and professionals
who are mercenaries,
and they'd rather lose
a professional campaign
than do anything high variance that might
put a black mark on their resume.
Mm hmm.
It reminds me of like these NFL coaches
who you can tell it's like they're
they're going to lose this game, but
they're not going to do anything too crazy
because like losing by seven
or ten seems more professional.
Yeah, but that's right.
So that
so there's like a political industrial
complex is around all the candidates.
And it's one
reason why people just seem like robots.
Mm hmm.
Yeah, that that wing ding story
that you tell about Avenatti and in Iowa,
I think, is pretty illustrative
of how the machinery operates.
Again, I'm so grateful to you, rich
and other independent voices.
And so my vision for what we need to do
to get ourselves out of this mess.
We need to build a new, independent,
positive solutions oriented
tribe and voice that's going to help
break up the duopoly and the polarization.
And we need to build a new constellation
of independent media voices
that people turn to and trust.
That's independent of the current Partizan
Corporate Media industrial complex.
Those are the two great projects
that I think can bring us back.
And those are the two projects
I'm devoting my waking life to.
Do you think it's possible
to create a news channel?
A cable news channel that is principled
in its relative objectivity
like to create news that's a little bit
more sane and grounded and less Partizan?
It is possible.
one of the defects of cable news
is just it's a lot of hours of programing
to fill, like if you stuck a camera
in front of me and said, Hey,
just like Bill twelve hours late,
you know it's going to get weird, right?
Well, we got C-SPAN for that.
Yeah, you.
But it is something
that a lot of people want right now.
And so when you say it's like, Hey,
could you create a sane
news channel or cable news channel?
It might not look like a cable news
channel.
Mm hmm.
What would it look like?
Well, I think it could look
like a whole crystal and saga.
It would be crystal and sogar across
different categories in different formats
where you could be, obviously,
you know, video
and podcast, but also
some programing that looks like cable news
channels, but isn't.
You know, again, 24-7.
So with the, you know, you just
launch this party, what is it like?
What's the day to day look like?
Like, where are you putting your focus
in terms of things
that you're trying to address and deal
with and take care of?
To advance the interests of this party
or organization building, it's good fun.
So if this is exciting to you listening,
go to forward party accom
and you can sign up.
You might even start
your own local chapter and then we'll get
some of these ballot initiatives going.
We will support local candidates
who can be running as Republicans,
independents, Democrats
who are aligned with some of these goals.
We are
making the case to the American people
in different ways.
We're raising money.
So it's movement building
and it's a lot of work.
But I am super energized and excited,
in part because the appetite is so great.
Like, I literally I was in a hotel
last night here in L.A.
and then just like the random person
at the door
who was working,
the door just looked at me
and yelled, Forward party,
you know, like, like you pumped.
Another young person came to me yesterday
and say the forward party
is the best thing to happen
in American politics in my lifetime,
so we just have to take that interest
and energy
and show people that it can be done.
And after we clear that hurdle,
then the sky's the limit.
Well,
I really appreciate your original voice
and I think we need more of this
kind of sensibility in our public
national conversation
and local conversation around politics.
And I think it's really cool
what you're doing.
So I'm a fan. I'm a supporter.
Thank you so much.
That means a ton to me.
This is going to be
the tribe of reasonableness and reason.
And I got to say, you're a charter member.
All right, buddy.
We'll come back and talk to me again
sometime.
Yeah, I would love that.
And if people want to learn more
or get down
with a forward party,
you just mentioned the website for that.
But pick up Andrew's new book Forward
Notes on the Future of Our Democracy,
available everywhere.
And you can also go to Andrew Yang
dot com, where, like all this stuff up,
including a book tour like I'm
going around giving book talks,
which have been
How is up the last I got to say rich.
Some of these are in comedy clubs
and so on.
Like, I'm living out this fantasy
where I'm talking about politics in
a comedy club. Yeah,
I was in New York.
I think when you had your
your first party,
first book party and I saw it
all on Twitter and I was pissed.
I oh shit, man, I was in a damage.
I would have had you over immediately
time.
Cool, buddy.
Well, take care, man,
and hopefully we'll talk again.
Definitely read. Thank you. Nice piece.